we take in these live pictures reaching
us from Wellington on the outskirts of
greater London which you can see for
yourselves a major incident has been
declared by the London fire brigade uh
not just because of this incident in
Wellington because of a number of fires
starting right across the city and
Southern England is in these soaring
temperatures the record temperature for
the UK has been broken today over 40
degrees Centigrade
the UK hit that new record 40.3 to be
precise in coningsby in Lincolnshire and
a temperature just slightly below that
was recorded at Heathrow Airport in West
London but let's concentrate on this
conflagration in Wellington in greater
London more than a hundred firefighters
are battling this fire there and a large
number of fire appliances as well it
appears to have started well some say in
grassland but so there are conflicting
accounts uh it's also been said it may
have started in a scrap yard this is of
course the the outskirts of London some
reports said started an explosion in a
scrap yard and then has spread to the
Tinder dry
grasslander setting Fields Ablaze and as
you can see for yourself that's a a row
of garages it seems on fire several
homes all also the previous shot we had
for you several homes have been
destroyed and are still burning in the
blaze also a church and it seems that
there are a a number of fires there
burning throughout that area clearly
firefighters have been able to
extinguish some of them but uh still a
lot of work to do it seems well let's
get the very latest on it all with uh
Jonathan Smith assistant commissioner at
the London fire brigade joins us from
Central London they're very good to talk
to you Mr Smith um tell us first of all
about what we are seeing in Wellington
now what are the what are the
circumstances how many resources are
deployed there by the London fire
brigade and what is the situation
so as you can see from the pictures the
situation is currently being brought
under control at its height we had uh
approximately 100 firefighters on scene
uh the situation remains very Dynamic
it's obviously spread out over a wide
area the conditions that our fire crews
are operating in uh are extremely
arduous because of the temperatures that
we're currently facing
um we this was uh one incident amongst
many that London Fire Crews have been
facing throughout today which was the
reason we declared a major incident
earlier uh this afternoon we were
dealing with not only this incident in
Weddington but a substantial incident uh
near upminster and across the capital
we've been dealing with a number of
grassland and Woodland type fires uh
that have been started as a result of
the particular heat wave that we're
facing at the moment and the fact that
the ground is so Tinderbox dry so our
resources today have been under
significant pressure which was part of
the reason for declaring the major
incident earlier today what I should say
though to provide reassurance is that
the London fire brigade is still
responding to emergency calls but we
would ask that when people are requiring
the London Fire brigadies for
life-threatening emergencies and fire
situations
um our resources are being deployed
dynamically across the capital as we
speak to bring these incidents under
control and we would ask actually that
people moderate their behavior over the
course of the next sort of 12 to 24
hours in particular by not having things
like barbecues out in Parkland and
Woodland by making sure that cigarettes
are extinguished properly by making sure
that rubbish and broken glass in
particular is not left lying around
which can cause a spark and Trigger uh
Wildfire
um we have been yeah under significant
pressure today but I'd just like to pay
Testament to our firefighters officers
and control staff who are have worked
extremely hard today to make sure that
the resources of the London fire brigade
have been able to bring these incidents
under control in partnership with our
emergency services in the metropolitan
police and the London Ambulance Service
and assistant commissioner could I ask
you in addition to what you mentioned
there about what the public can do could
I add in perhaps if they spot even a you
know a small Blaze some smoldering going
on in a in a piece of grass it may seem
trivial at that point but would it be
worth reporting on the basis that given
how tender dry given the conditions that
you describe that could easily spread
no that's absolutely right so it's
really really important that people call
999 and ask for the fire brigade when
they do see any fires however small they
may be because as a result of the
temperatures that we've seen over the
last week and in particular the last two
days the ground is extremely dry and
acts like a Tinderbox so even a small
fire will develop very very quickly if
it's not tackled effectively and
efficient efficiently in its early
stages we would also say to people that
they don't try and Tackle fires
themselves the situation that you can
see is extremely Dynamic and these fires
can develop very very quickly and we
would not want to see members of the
public exposing themselves to
unnecessary risk the London fire brigade
and other Fire and Rescue Services
across the UK have very well trained
very well prepared and very well
equipped firefighters to deal with these
incidents so we would urge the public
not to try and take them on themselves
but to make sure that they call us at
the earlier stop opportunity because the
earlier we get that information the
earlier we can mobilize and the earlier
we can bring these incidents under
control
and is it areas talking about greater
London of course it goes for all our
major contributions is it areas like
this on the outskirts of the major
cities where there you know there's a
mix we we all know the terrain there's a
there's a mix of grassland Woodland
maybe some scrub land as well therefore
it's not just all buildings and and
tarmac which I imagine is harder to set
on fire you you're in danger of getting
these situations developing where
something can develop in the Woodland or
in the grass and then spread to
buildings from there
well interestingly London's actually one
of the the sort of greenest cities in in
Europe in terms of the amount of green
space that there is even in even in
central London so you're right to point
to the fact that the suburbs tend to
have more grassland more Fields more
Woodland uh but actually we do see
significant areas of uh green spaces in
central London as well so at first it
may appear that wildfire and grass and
fires in particular are not always a
major issue for urban brigades like
London fire brigade actually that's not
the case we do have significant areas of
green areas in central London and on the
outskirts so it's very much a clear and
present threat for us to make sure that
we're prepared and ready to respond to
these incidents as and when they occur
and just to be very clear for us I just
want to revisit the Declaration of a
major incident assistant commissioner
what does that mean in practice what are
the ramifications of it of course it
tells the public how serious the
situation is you've already said that
there is uh no then knock on danger to
the existing cover and safety that the
fire service provide for us but what
does it mean in terms of resources for
you do you bring people back from a
day's leave do you have access to other
forces other parts of the emergency
services to help out
well what it really does is it triggers
a lot of our multi-agency Arrangements
that we've got in place for London so
when any one agency or more than one
agency declares a major incident what it
does is it triggers well-rehearsed and
well practiced planning Arrangements
across uh not only the Emergency
Services uh but local government and and
the mayor's office uh as well as partner
agencies to make sure that actually what
we've got is the full force of London's
um services and partner agencies working
together in a collaborative way to bring
this incident under control because
although what you're seeing primarily at
the moment are fire related issues they
of course have a knock-on impact on
people's housing on people's welfare on
people's health and safety and so what
we need to do is make sure that we've
got that coordinated pan- London
approach bringing together all of the
key agencies working to a cohesive
strategy uh to work to bring not only
the fires and the other emergencies
under control all but to get London back
to normal as soon as possible so by
declaring a major incident what that
does is it triggers a lot of that key
partnership working which then enables
us to get back to a sense of normality
as soon as possible and operationally
specifically looking at Wellington what
is the information the latest you have
on how much under control that is now by
the fire service
so the situation is being brought under
control it Still Remains very very
dynamic because
um as you can see in in your pictures
where you've got areas that appear to be
out they can reignite very very quickly
particularly given the very very dry
nature of the land that it's currently
on so we are going to have our resources
there for a significant period of time
making sure that we're turning over and
damping down to prevent any further
escalation of the incident and stopping
any chance of a reignition which is
something that is a real prevalence when
you're dealing with these types of
incidents because of the nature of the
ground and its dried condition at the
moment any small spark or any area that
we do not put out properly could run the
risk of reignition so we will have
resources there throughout the night
making sure that we're bringing this
into them under control
and what you've been describing to a
senator system commissioner is I suppose
resilience in action this is an incident
which clearly you're not aware it's
going to happen but given the
circumstances given the forecast you
were looking at given the the training
and the coordination you've described to
us between the variety of emergency
services this is something that you've
been well prepared for and been able to
respond to very quickly
that's right so we've got well rehearsed
multi-agency training in place to make
sure uh that we're able to respond to
these types of incidents as and when
they occur we've obviously had
experience recently as last year around
wide area flooding for example which had
a similar pan London impact uh and
required the full resource of the London
fire brigade to be able to bring those
incidents under control
these climate-related challenges that we
know we are now facing are things that
we are for properly putting into our
longer term strategic planning to make
sure that the Brigade is as resourced
and as prepared as they possibly can be
to deal with these incidents as and when
they occur but the the position that
London finds itself in is that we have
got well rehearsed well-practiced
multi-agency plans in place to deal with
exactly this type of challenge when it's
actually pan London
um and actually that's been brought to
bear throughout today and as I say I
would I would just once again
put credit towards our firefighters and
officers and control staff and emergency
service Partners who have worked
incredibly hard and extremely arduous
conditions to bring these incidents
under control and Mr Swift what is the
latest on the people involved in this
incident in Wellington we could see at
least six rather large houses in a row
well virtually destroyed certainly the
roof's gone and been hosed down by the
fire service are there any reports of
any casualties or has everyone either
been outdoor or got out safely
so we've not had formal reports on the
number of casualties come through yet
because as you can see this Still
Remains a very Dynamic uh incident so
we're still waiting on the latest
information as far as casualty numbers
are concerned what I can say is that
we've got significant resource at the
scene and bringing this incident under
control as quickly as possible but
obviously this will be subject uh to a
significant investigation to try and
ascertain the cause of the fire but at
the moment uh I'm unable to comment on
any potential casualties well thank you
for that it's going to be a long night
though isn't it it's going to be a long
week it's going to be a a long summer
how you you talk about the preparedness
but the resources you have to deploy how
long can they keep it up for
well as I say we've got well rehearsed
plans in place we've got relief
Arrangements in place so our crews who
will be coming on to the night shift uh
in a couple of hours time will be
getting ready and prepared so that they
can take over from Crews on on who have
been operating throughout today and that
will continue uh throughout the week
we've got proper plans in place we
understand that this is a long-term
challenge that we need to we need to
face but because of those plans because
of the training that we've got and
because of our ability to coordinate our
response across the capital we're
confident that we're able to to bring
these incidents under control and then
to make sure we've got the resources
available for what will continue to be a
very challenging week for us
assistant commissioner Jonathan swifter
very reassuring talking to you very
informative of course thank you very
much indeed we know you've got an awful
lot to deal with uh thank you very much
indeed for sparing the time to talk to
us on Sky News